mais avant que l'histoire de cet homme
en attente depuis quatre ans d'une
transplantation cardiaque il devait être
joignable jour et nuit sur son portable
pour le cas où l'hôpital qui le suivait
à disposerait d'un coeur pour lui
constatant que ça lignes téléphoniques
étaient coupées il appelle son opérateur
qui lui permet un cubi promet un
rétablissement dans les 48 heures 48
heures de trop hervé ghesquière marque
une malchance qui confine au drame
gilles jaulin gravement malade du coeur
doit subir une transplantation depuis
2002 mais il n'y avait pas de donneur
jusqu'au 20 février dernier ce jour-là
l'hôpital marseillais de la timone
appelle le patient son téléphone
portable reste muet l'opérateur bouygues
telecom avait interrompu la ligne depuis
quatre jours ils se sont justifiés en
disant qu'ils avaient des problèmes des
problèmes informatiques pour réactiver
la puce
mais qui ferait au plus vite et toutes
les heures je leur disais que j'étais en
attente de greffe cardiaque et que pour
moi c'était vital d'avoir mon télécom
bouygues télécom affirment avoir coupé
la ligne à cause d'un non paiement mais
aujourd'hui l'opérateur semble réaliser
la situation on se met à la place de nos
clients et on a tous été bouleversés
au niveau de la direction générale d'
apprendre de ce qui s'était produit
c'est la première fois en dix ans qu'on
se trouve dans une cette situation et
on en est désolé pour pour lui et pour
sa famille une réponse qui a déjà été
donnée à gilles jaulin il y a quelques
semaines apparemment pas très
convaincante
cet opérateur que j'ai eu à la direction
en dernier il ya un mois du monde est
bon on comprend ce qui s'est passé en
progrès qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais
on se met à votre place je pense que ces
gens là ne se situe mais pour arriver à
se mettre à la place quelqu'un qui est
condamné
gilles jaulin a décidé d'assigner en
justice les opérateurs de téléphonie
mobile mais cet homme de 44 ans attend
toujours un coeur